they can't help it
they have an itch
they are sick
quarantine these today
we must cure the world welcome back to
the rock stars obi-wan kenobi is giving
us i think my new favorite description
of the jedi in all of star wars the jedi
cannot help what they are the genetic
code is like an itch they cannot help it
but what exactly does a green inquisitor
mean by that and what are this lines
implications for
this is wikileaks our weekly reaction to
the latest and greatest in star wars i'm
here with tommy bechtol tommy how you
doing if the jedi code is like an itch
then i certainly caught the jedi code
last time i was in vegas that is true
what happens in vegas doesn't stay it
stays right on your crotch for at least
three to seven days until the ointment
kicks in
we are less than a month away from the
premiere of obi-wan kenobi and today
we're going to talk about why the great
inquisitor keeps talking about the jedi
code like it's the herp yeah i like the
heart babe
now uh so we are almost out of these
moon knight lanes obsession shirts over
at new rockstarsmerch.com we got maybe
single digits left of those you got to
get on those they're going to be
banished back to the blue dungeon uh to
make grouper a multiverse man's latest
obsession shirt it's multiverse the
madness week here ah
so uh grab these and all kinds of other
cool merch that help support our channel
at neuroxmerch.com and of course
today it may already be live on the
channel while you're watching this
continue watching this video and then
you can go watch recording this later
the break room it is new rockstar's
daily live show
coming to the channel today uh uh monday
may the second and then every weekday
here after it's gonna be unlike anything
we've ever done in new rockstars the
whole team is very excited about it uh
tommy is gonna be a regular picture on
the show alongside jessica clemons
brandon barrick you might see me there
might see me there today i don't know if
i can run down from where i am to uh to
the office we want you eric we want you
with us i've got a room i'll tell you
what you can sit on lefty or righty your
choice
two knees two booster seats that's right
only one fun
uh
the thing is though i'm not gonna be
there every time because i you don't
need me there every time these folks are
heavyweights over there the funniest
people in the world uh and i'm gonna be
busy still making all the great content
that you came to new rockstars for uh
it's gonna be a wonderful conversation
every week the break room is gonna be
responding to stuff i make on the
channel calling me on my [ __ ] uh or
building me up when i needed it oh yeah
gassing you up mostly baby gassing you
up we're like a weekly whip it for you
it's just gonna give uh our new rockstar
subscribers a chance to interact with uh
with the hosts in uh real time uh ask
some live questions get some thoughts on
your theories and sometimes i'll be
there most of the time i won't be but
it's going to be great i'm going to be
watching every day
well we appreciate it and we're very
very very excited so check it out well
tommy what's our first question uh this
week in star wars oh yes eric we talked
about it before but why does the grand
inquisitor call the jedi code an itch
yes it's
such an amazing descriptor for
the way the jedi are perceived in this
era of star wars now we have to remind
everyone that the grand inquisitor was
himself a jedi as all inquisitors were
or at least force sensitive you know but
he specifically was established by dave
felony and all star wars canon as one of
those jedi who were there for the
prosecution of ahsoka tano in the
prosecution of barris offi he saw in
that moment firsthand how the jedi code
can sometimes be misplaced in their
judgment and a little be a little too
high and mighty that experience left him
scarred with this now predominant
prevailing point of view that the jedi
are some kind of scourge on all of
society i love this description so much
because it it hints at this orthodoxy
that is now uh
coursing through the inquisitors uh and
through darth vader and i'm sure
palpatine has been uh sending out this
propaganda that uh the jedi are right to
be hunted down that the jedi have been a
curse have been uh a toxin a poison in
society in their dogma that they have
separated force sensitive kids from
their families uh and they've been
manipulative using jedi tricks in order
to convince these farmers or these poor
families to hand over their babies these
are toddlers that the jedi have been uh
have been recruiting from young ages how
creepy was it phantom menace when yoda
and the other jedi masters were like no
this nine-year-old is too old yeah two
old yeah gross you're creepo your pervs
taking these babies from home from
younger than that age right uh how young
you need to go it's a great parallel to
you know what we have here in our real
world with religions that paint their
opposition as extremists and the ones
that do all the radical uh heinous
things i mean it happens and we don't
get into it and take any specific sides
but it just is very interesting like
yeah the sith who we generally in star
wars review as the bad guys are like
yeah but look these guys are the bad
guys and here's why all we want is law
and order and what these guys want to do
is rip people's families apart and have
all of these strict rules they're like
the people that are like the strict
biblical interpreters they're like well
if it says it in the bible then that's
exactly how we do it even though it's
2022 and we have all this technology and
science that makes a more compassionate
living situation so it is it's a great
metaphor and it's a great uh it's a
great parallel that we can kind of all
latch on to when we're watching it's
certainly a chilling metaphor it's so
specific and it's
stealing you know he he can speak from
first-hand experience the way that like
yoda described the force to to luke on
dagobah the way luke described it to rey
it's always been presented as this
mystical kind of tug this
sensation a spidey sense in a way that
we kind of wish that we could have but
here for him to turn that into something
that is like a mosquito bite uh
something that is like almost like a
feeling of withdrawal yeah sticks a like
uh a creepy crawly like crazy
yeah right it's the word itch is just so
brilliant writing like i i love it so
much now i guess my question is
uh i understand philosophically where
he's coming from right like i compare
this to the fact like hans landa
describing his anti-semitism
uh and the way that the the empire has
been called space nazis george lucas
intentionally wanted that parallel to be
the case and now it's like we're getting
back to that of like the way that the
nazis were able to like
justify their inhumanity uh and their
their genocide as this kind of uh this
this cleansing this moral crusade of
like we have to hunt down every last one
of these people because they represent
uh a toxic force it's terrifying it is
innately terrifying to hear someone talk
that way about another class of people
now i guess my question for you tommy is
what do you think the context of this
quote is is this something the grand
inquisitor like in uh like in starship
troopers him marching down yeah
of other of other inquisitors like
lecturing them on why they need to do
this or is he torturing someone is he
torturing luminar and dooley in this
moment well he's saying
it's one i think it's either that or he
he is uh
almost like a uh like he's preaching to
a group of of people in order to gain
their
their allegiance like you know if like
you know
the problematic uh if you see something
say something like this is the thing if
you people
you know if you see force sensitive
people
uh you need to let us know because
they're going to end up becoming like
this this worst case scenario which for
the sith is a jedi right so i think it's
probably he's fight he's gassing up the
troops probably more than likely like
he's like walking by and being like
these are the enemy this is why we need
to get him but i could see it also being
him
kind of speaking to a neutral crowd or
maybe a crowd that is against him but
not violently attacking him but is still
listening
uh in order to gain their uh
maybe sway them sway their opinions the
court of public opinion rather yeah i
think so too i believe he says they
cannot help it yeah and it almost feels
like he's saying this to like a crowd of
onlookers and tattooing as he is
executing some forces to run away and
he's like this is why i'm doing what i'm
doing and if you see say you see
something you must say something because
these people are sick and they will make
you sick it's an itch they cannot help
it so i'm mercifully putting him down
you know it seems like he's justifying
it in a way but like man oh man i like i
am both terrified of this being true but
part of me wants to see this happen is
the capture of luminar unduly they have
that relationship i thought it was so
creepy in rebels the way that the grand
inquisitor
used her corpse to lure in ezra and
kanan yeah it was one of the darker
things we've seen yeah in animated star
wars uh like someone's corpse being used
in that way it's just really messed up
um so if we do see something with a
grain inquisitor i i think the capture
of luminor and duly is a way that you
could really show how fearsome this
character is
absolutely well i can't wait to see the
context of this line we've actually
heard quite a bit of uh star wars news
this week that i just want to share with
you all so debra chao did an uh
interview with uh total film uh as we're
looking ahead uh to to obi-wan kenobi's
premiere on the 27th uh she said that
two western films inspired the uh the
tone that she's going for the
assassination of jesse james by the
coward robert ford oh cool
uh and the proposition now i've not seen
the proposition but i have seen the
assassination of jesse james brad pitt
casey affleck an incredible film
and what i think uh stands out to me
about what she may mean by that instead
of just in addition to the visual style
uh and how stark that is how desaturated
that movie was is uh the sense of uh
betrayal there is almost like
uh like a judas in the in the garden uh
quality to that film like is obi-wan
gonna have someone close to him who he
can't trust who feels the need to betray
him is that is is moses ingram's
character riva the second sister is she
gonna be the coward robert ford of this
movie
yeah
whoever turns in someone anyway we'll
talk about that more in the coming weeks
we want to thank someone who helped us
make this episode our friends at peloton
they get a peloton for sponsoring this
episode you may not feel like you have
time to fit into a workout into your day
i know i don't always have time between
making videos to head to a gym or to a
park to have a full workout but that's
what i like about peloton they offer a
variety of workouts that you can do from
the comfort of your own home because
peloton is a team of world-class
instructors ready to motivate you 24 7
whatever your fitness level pelotons
highly trained fitness pros don't just
teach they motivate peloton has
thousands of live and on-demand classes
so you can always keep it fresh from
cycling and strength training to yoga
and running you're more likely to stick
to a workout routine you enjoy so
peloton makes every class fun so it
feels like you're just hanging out with
friends and whatever music you're into
you'll find the perfect soundtrack for
your workout on peloton and the best
part about peloton is that it works with
your schedule whether you have five
minutes or an hour plus you'll never
have an awkward encounter in that locker
room ever again
thank god
because we have an itch we can't help it
that's right and it's itches aren't
taken kindly in locker rooms it just
gets no they aren't it just gets
stitches
so right now is the perfect time to try
out feliton the peloton bike plus is now
500 less it's the best price yet
including free delivery and setup and
there are more game changing prices
available on the original peloton bike
and peloton tread visit onepeloton.com
to learn more all right uh tommy we
learned this week uh the star wars
celebration 2022 schedule in anaheim
there's gonna be some really really
exciting panels on thursday may 26th the
day before obi-wan premieres on disney
plus um there's going to be the
lucasfilm studio showcase where we're
going to see teases for obi-wan kenobi
of course as well as andor and the
mandalorian season three uh and then on
saturday may 28th uh there's going to be
a mando plus uh panel with john favreau
and dave filoni we'll really learn some
more followed by that at 1 p.m on
saturday behind the scenes of the
mandalorian in the book of boba fett in
which robert rodriguez and his uh his
team is going to be joining the
conversation as well as uh on sunday
there's gonna be a bad batch season two
panel but conspicuously absent from all
these announcements is anything related
to star wars rogue squadron
uh
we did get a news update in
recent months that it had been delayed
or just not delayed but just kind of
like taken off of its release date
schedule it just kind of like
uh delayed indeterminately without any
particular release date uh i think patty
jenkins might still be attached to it
right that was my big question yes is
she yeah we don't we don't know what's
going on there but like we should talk
about what's going on with rogue
squadron and what's going on with star
wars movies
like will we ever see another star wars
movie or are they done for now i think
that it is right now it's in a very
there's like a fragile ecosystem right
now with star wars uh you know on-screen
content because it's like mandalorian is
a super hit right like mandalorian is
book of boba fett still got a ton of
views but people critic it was heavily
criticized right like there was some
confusion
about like why was there so much mando
why was grogu why were they central plot
points to this book of boba fett you
know even we theorized like maybe that
they had kind of abandoned telling a
full boba fett standalone story because
of whether or not they just felt i'm
wondering if the thing here with things
like rogue squadron if they're like are
we going too niche
like with our star wars titles and do we
need to kind of bring it back to
these big spectacle
tentpole trilogies like do like if we're
gonna do films does it need to be a new
trilogy not a skywalker saga but a new
trilogy in that world maybe some
connecting characters or some connective
tissue to kind of you know bring it
around
and i also think they're waiting to see
how kenobi does i think they're waiting
to see like i think we're all really
excited about kenobi everybody you know
we're all
hoping it's a home run and i think that
there's kind of been a wait and see
right now and of all the titles that
they have ahsoka seems like a more of a
guarantee than rogue squadron to me in
terms of like people responding well to
it so i get why that's moving forward
and we have announcements on that i
think ahsoka seems more likely i think
you know it seems like a more of a
guaranteed like uh hit i think they're
probably just waiting to see like are
people's gonna be ravenous for more star
wars content or is this fatigue this
wave of fatigue that we saw with the
with the solo and you know
kind of the the delayed reaction to the
to the new
the new uh trilogy is that gonna be the
kind of the norm now and are they
smarter just to release a couple shows a
year is that the better financial move
so i i think this is a business thing
uh but i want to see it i think we
really i thought i don't know if the
fatigue is that song i think it's just
put out
good things you know like deliver on the
promise of what the show is saying it's
going to be and i think the fans will be
i mean the real fans that are reasonable
which is you know asking a lot we'll be
okay with it so my guess is that they're
just waiting to see how these next
couple shows perform before they invest
you know 200 million dollars in it right
and i would say you don't need to put
200 million dollars in it i think that's
also kind of the misunderstanding
uh but
star wars just doesn't have a good model
yet for releasing a film that can be
done
on a lower budget i mean they try to do
it with rogue one but then they end up
like pouring money into reshoots they
try to do a solo but then they fire the
directors and they hired ron howard and
poured a ton of money into that right um
i think what you need is just give bryce
dallas howard a movie yeah to direct
give dave felony a movie john favreau a
movie all three of these directors know
how to do it isn't it supposed to be
getting a movie is that still happening
there there's been talks there's been
talks that taiko's gonna get one that
ryan johnson's still attached that kevin
feige was gonna get one yeah um yeah so
i i think right now they're keeping
their options open maybe in by the end
of this month they'll announce what the
next movie is going to be yeah it kind
of feels like we're in um
star wars or star trek the next
generation era where they're they're
putting
the franchise on the heels of a
television series
and then at some point they're going to
turn those into movies uh
i hope that they have better luck than
the the
picard era of films did um
hey come on don't dunk on generations
[Laughter]
but i think like
they have an opportunity here they have
lots of great characters that are uh
specific to the television world that
could totally work on screen and are
big screen actors uh
as soon as they cast thrawn i think
there's an entire
um
universe of films that can be made just
following thrawn
uh i think they just need to figure out
what era they want to live in yep and as
much as i love the uh the mandalorian
boba fett era
uh of tv series that's not necessarily
my favorite era of history to start of
star wars history because it forces you
to connect to like the first order in
snoke and all this [ __ ] and like yeah i
don't need to live in that era for films
i think there's a more exciting era if
you just go back and maybe they're gonna
wait till the acolyte comes out and
there's like a whole
era of stories or maybe something long
after
uh the rise of skywalker there's
something in the far future there's like
a new reset that does not feel anything
like what we've seen before but
you know it just explores the jedi it's
just the problem is like the jedi
history on the big screen for now has
just been so infused with the skywalker
saga yeah we don't need the skywalker
saga anymore no it concluded i mean it's
whether you love it or hate it it
concluded and that's okay you know like
that is yeah it's fine we're all going
to be i just don't think they're going
to have another good star wars movie
until they can get over order 66. don't
get me wrong i love order 66. i want all
these things to like show me order 66
from different angles but like the more
you uh you know tie yourself down to
what happened in the prequels and the
stuff in the skywalker saga the more
doors you close yeah were kind of the
kind of movies you can tell
um so i think what excited me about
rogue squadron is it seems like just
returning to
what i love about the 1977 film is just
the trench run seeing
seeing x-wings and y-wings uh take on
tie fighters
through a trench it's just freaking fun
yeah and anytime star wars has gone back
to the wars
whether it's rogue one or whatever i'm
i'm all for it uh so i would love like
just a pilot-centric story in the star
wars universe top gun in this top gun in
space baby give it to me yeah yeah um i
think they have the right people to do
it i i think ultimately it's probably
for the best like take your time get it
right
um it's just interesting to be at this
point where one of the biggest pieces of
ip
ever in the history of all time and
currently still huge
uh has no movies slated yeah anywhere in
the future yeah
i mean that's also can be a symptom of
everything being owned by the same
companies now it's like disney's got so
much marvel content coming out that
they're probably like yeah all right
fine
filonia and favreau and you guys
you know figure out what's going on over
at lucas and like
let us get back to us but we're good
we're good well we will leave it there
uh i can't wait for uh for this month to
happen
that's right that's right uh so happy
early may the fourth to you all yes um
and uh we will check in next week so be
sure uh to follow each of us on social
media you can follow me at ea of us
follow tommy tommy beck told follow new
rock stars subscribe to wikileaks
wherever you get your podcast thanks for
watching goodbye
you